A staple of daytime TV since 1972, The Price
is Right is the longest-running game show
in American television history.
Hosted by the iconic Bob Barker for more than
35 years and 7,000 episodes, it's continued
to thrive after Barker's retirement under
the stewardship of comedian Drew Carey.
But how much do you actually know about this
television institution?
Here's a look at the untold truth of the Price
is Right.
Let's Make a Deal
When The Price is Right debuted in 1972, it
was actually titled The New Price is Right,
a title it kept for a little under a year.
That's because it was loosely based on a primetime
game show that had aired as early as 1956,
where contestants won small prizes by guessing
how much household items cost.
But by the '70s, the original concept was
deemed too boring.
Instead, CBS told producer Mark Goodson that
if he wanted to revive the Price is Right,
he should look at their hit game show Let's
Make a Deal for inspiration.
He did, borrowing a slew of gimmicks, like
pulling people out of the studio audience
to be contestants, using lights and sound
effects to get the crowd hyped, and having
the contestants play lots of different little
games, like the cultural phenomenon Cliff
Hangers.
"There's no way that microwave costs more
than 300 bucks.
Stop here.
Don't listen to that fat tourist, he doesn't
know how much a microwave costs!"
"I can't find dad!"
"Oh, God, no!
Oh, God, no!
Where is he?!"
"Hans!
Hans!
Where are you?!
Oh, my God."
"Dad?"
The best of the best
Every game show has a different process for
contestant selection.
Jeopardy!, for example, is quite rigorous,
putting prospective guests through multiple
written tests, an interview, and a live test
version of the game against other hopefuls.
The Price is Right is far more immediate.
On taping days, contestants/studio audience
members line up for as long as four hours
outside Bob Barker Studio at CBS Television
City in Los Angeles.
Then, ten at a time, they're herded in front
of a producer who asks them each one question,
where they've got to show off a sparkling
personality and lots of energy.
Only about 100 people or so get picked to
sit in the studio audience, and the lucky
contestants find out they've been selected
when the announcer calls their name.
"How about if we call Katie Hudson, COME ON
DOWN!
YOU'RE the next contestant on The Price Is
Right!"
Showcase Showdown showdown
In 2008, a huge Price is Right fan named Terry
Kniess was picked to "come on down" to Contestant's
Row.
He made it all the way to the Showcase Showdown,
where he did something that nobody in the
show's history had done, before or since:
He guessed the exact price of his prize package.
Taping stopped for almost an hour, as the
producers and host Drew Carey were sure Kneiss
had cheated.
But he hadn't.
Instead, he had studied the show for years,
and realized that many prizes were repeated.
So he memorized the prices of all the prizes
and added them up in his head during his appearance.
As a result, he won both showcase prize pools,
and the Price is Right changed their prize
structure to include more variance in price
structure.
"You bid $23,743.
Actual retail price?
$23,743, you got it right on the nose."
Replacing a legend
Finding a replacement for Barker wasn't easy.
The search was so difficult, in fact, that
he even offered to delay his retirement if
a new host couldn't be found in time.
Numerous stars secretly recorded mock episodes
as host, including George Hamilton, Ian Ziering,
Mario Lopez, John O'Hurley, Antiques Roadshow
host Mark Walberg, and former Double Dare
host Marc Summers.
Summers was Bob Barker's first choice as replacement,
but after CBS chairman Les Moonves saw Carey
hosting the prime time game show Power of
10, he offered Carey the gig.
Too bad Adam Sandler didn't audition!
"The price is wrong, bitch!"
A BRAND NEW CAR!
As Benjamin Franklin once famously said, only
two things in life are certain: Plinko and
taxes.
And California takes their game show taxes
very seriously.
They actually treat game show winnings as
income, and contestants are required to pay
taxes on the spot before they can take their
prizes home.
Luckily, many contestants also win money on
the show in addition to prizes, so it's common
for them to pay taxes using their prize money.
And there's a bunch of red tape around that
brand new car, too.
Winners don't drive home with their sweet
ride.
Instead, the show sends them to a local dealership
to coordinate delivery of the vehicle at a
dealership near the contestant's home - assuming
they have already paid all those taxes and
registration fees first.
"It's your BRAND NEW CAR!"